listen do whatever the [ __ ] you want to
do whenever you want to do it and unless
you harm somebody else and or put them
in jeopardy [ __ ] it
hi I'm Ted baliker with Reason TV and
today I'll be speaking with Adam Corolla
Corolla began podcasting in 2009 and the
Adam Carolla show quickly became one of
the most downloaded podcasts on iTunes
he's also releasing a book in 50 years
we'll all be chicks available for
pre-order we caught up with Adam in his
warehouse which serves as a recording
studio and a garage for his many sports
cars so you've got a kind of a guy dream
set up here this is a garage / studio
yeah well I mean obviously there's a lot
of overcompensation going on here
clearly I'm gay it's like I don't want
people to know about it you know like a
guy feels like a coward your challenge
is everyone to fight yeah totally this
is me what you're seeing when you're a
manifestation of my struggle with my
sexuality and possibly yours and maybe
even Zach's yeah you know mike has lost
that struggle why should he act clearly
he's been beaten by his own sexuality
quite soundly yeah you're a real car guy
- you got the kind of Ferris Bueller's
Yeah right here oh yeah this delightful
thing with the roof missing they call
those yeah that's that's that's an AC
Cobra tribute car I guess it's like
bands they don't wanna be cover bands
I'm gonna be tribute fans that's a clone
essentially not my car my cars are all
actually sadly my cars have all been
pushed out into the parking lot to make
room for my idiot buddies cars here's
the whole thing where's my camera Ted is
this my camera it's just a cautionary
tale okay if any of you are thinking
about becoming successful and buying a
warehouse in your hometown where you
grew up with all your a-hole jackoff
Loser buddies don't do it move out of
town or meet a whole new group of rich
people and then buy a warehouse because
if you stay in the same town you grew up
in all your buddies will just move all
their garb
which into your warehouse yeah your
entourage right and we had to just blow
this place out just a couple weeks ago
actually to get it to look how it is
today so what do you make you know you
your car guy you love cars what do you
make of all these people who say that
cars are evil these days who said that
did names and what numbers or know that
name don't know give Alec Goering you
know they say form just like I'm gonna
Gore Zack talked into yeah that's that's
on your time Zack yeah I mean obviously
it's sort of that that kind of thing
where everything has a good sign a bad
side like you know guns good if a cop
has one and bad if a [ __ ] has one and
cars good if they get good mileage and
they don't admit too much sulfur and
there's eight people in it you're in one
of those diamond lanes man you're right
that sucks
here's my plan tell me if it sounds too
elitist all right ed but it probably
does okay it is but but hear me out hear
me out
are you ready I'm ready gas
ten bucks a gallon now okay now hold on
that's easy for you yeah uh you're
dealing I got a van cuz it was like Oh
what about poor people how they gonna
afford the ten bucks
they're not gonna afford the ten bucks
I'm gonna save them a bunch of money
because if you think about it you live
out here in Southern California you got
your car payment you got insurance which
many folks can't even afford and then
you have expensive gas well how about
this I'm gonna send a van to your house
pick you up drive you to work with 80
other people stuffed in it and then
they're gonna pick you up at work and
they're gonna drive you back to your
home bus is free light rails free
monorail is free just like Disneyland
all for free because of my extra $7 on
every gallon of gas being sold meanwhile
it's just gonna be me and Richard
Branson having a drag race down the 405
8:30 in the morning on a Tuesday nobody
on the road me just drunk and doing
donuts in the middle of the 101 pull any
breaks so you're gonna run against your
guy here we go
to propose that yes the Ragosa you know
that's not his real name right
it's one of those mushed together names
yeah it was a tip of the sombrero to his
wife who he loves very much when he's
not [ __ ] reporters from Telemundo
he's an awesome guy failed the bar four
times a dude who failed the bar four
times would you want him like working
with your kids or piloting an airplane
or even a school bus I mean he failed
the bar four times and he's running give
him the keys of the second one of the
seventh seventh largest economy well
we're not seventh anymore he's driven us
down but the point is we're given the
keys to this city and he's essentially
functionally [ __ ] we did this
documentary with Drew Carey about how he
could fix his hometown of Cleveland do
you think your hometown of LA is in
worse shape than Cleveland yes it's
[ __ ] and potholes and we're totally
[ __ ]
we had Bryan Cranston on the podcast a
couple of months back pretty bad guy
Breaking Bad guy shows his butt all the
time yeah yeah they even seen some some
back sack on Cranston the point is this
I was driving him to the Burbank Airport
after he did the podcast and on the way
to driving him to the airport I said
isn't Breaking Bad supposed to be in
Riverside California and he said yeah
I'm going into Mexico and I said well
why are you going to New Mexico to shoot
a series that was originally supposed to
take place in Riverside or did take
place in Riverside and he said taxes
baby even they go to Prague if they got
to shoot a movie they go to Canada
they've to shoot a movie they go to
Louisiana or North Carolina or in this
case New Mexico why we all leaving Tim
Robbins and all these other deal weeds
are timeless hey man let's tax the rich
how come these [ __ ] hop on a plane
and leave town gladly I mean we they're
not doing the math on that why Weiss
Nissan going to Tennessee or wherever
the [ __ ] they want why why does every
business just pack up and leave you
raise the taxes people pack up
leave you [ __ ] retards you guys don't
understand that concept
mayor Corolla unseats VAR what do you do
Tony Villar yeah well first thing I do
is make it more business-friendly so
everybody doesn't [ __ ] pack up and
leave I mean we're Hollywood and nobody
shoots here that's kind of disgusting
isn't it I mean all the studios are here
all the actors are here all the
hairstylist and everyone is here and
they all pack up in the least report in
the Shreveport shoot for six months so
first thing I would do is I would lower
I would give a break and incentive to
business to stay here and work so
everyone wouldn't just pick up and leave
because they get a big chunk but a big
chunk of nothing so yeah how much money
you're getting from Nissan Nissan split
40% of zero is zero you ass wife's so
just take 20% and have them stay in town
that's just I'm doing this [ __ ]
academic probation at La Valle College
you as like the bar for it yes okay you
failed the bar four times you still
can't do this [ __ ] math it certainly
we have a problem with traffic in this
city it doesn't move very well every
single campaign we do is involving slow
it down or click it or ticket now let me
just say this click it or ticket do we
really need this public service campaign
isn't there a placard there's ads you
have a chime that goes off inside your
car that doesn't stop unless you put
your seatbelt in right you have a
placard that lights up on your dashboard
until you put your seatbelt in this is
every car that was manufactured since
like 1974 so why do we need expensive
campaigns telling us to put our
seatbelts on when we all have cars that
tell us to put our seatbelts on and then
so on every freeway sign just says click
it or ticket report drunk driving you
know it's basically slow and steady wins
the race
slow down for the cone zone how about a
campaign that says shake your ass about
a campaign that says you know Mach
schnell wake up how about this and I'm
dead
goddamn serious about this just dig this
for a second la is a group of lethargic
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that just
drive around at a snail's pace
completely out of it and have no idea
what's going on
it's utterly legal to turn right on a
red in the city of Los Angeles and in
the state of California I [ __ ] drive
around all goddamn day long and honk at
people that are just parked at a red
light when it's perfectly safe to turn
right on a red but does via Ragosa or
Tony Ragosa or Tony Villar or via Tony
Villar whatever's real made-up name is
does he try to do any campaign to
educate people about that it's nothing
but click it or ticket
we got the [ __ ] message on seatbelts
we understand the seatbelt part how
about it's illegal to turn right on a
red how about that how about wake up and
move along how about if we see people
just holding up and dragging people or
slowing down traffic we'll bust those
people how about when people break down
on the freeway like you got four bald
tires and one of them blows out and you
take up the whole fast lane on the 405
you got $1,000 fine jackoff how about we
focus on getting people to move instead
of slow it down slow and steady put the
seat belt on [ __ ] yo get people moving
and calibrate those goddamn left-turn
arrows so they don't [ __ ] sit there
with a red arrow and a green light he's
just sitting there rotting waiting to be
t-boned by a drunk trucker in the middle
of [ __ ] nowhere the point is this hey
all I want to say where's my camera
everybody here drive through the left
turn red arrows I do it every single
[ __ ] day of my life it's the greatest
thing that ever happened to me it is
completely liberating I used to sit
there like an [ __ ] I used to work in
Culver City what do love line at night
and I've drive home down like Culver
Boulevard or whatever and I'd end up
just sitting there it's 12:30 at night I
can see the [ __ ] horizon I can see
the curve of the earth in front of me no
cars coming green light but just sitting
they're like an [ __ ] like a [ __ ]
sheep like a lemming sitting there
waiting for the man to let me know it
was okay to turn left you know I know
it's okay to turn left there's no [ __ ]
cars coming how do you figure it out at
every other intersection and you know
what I've done it for six years and I've
never gotten a ticket so [ __ ] you
[ __ ] [ __ ] and let me say this
there if I got a if I got a ticket
tomorrow it's there'll be a thousand
years ahead of the [ __ ] game and
here's the reason why I've never gotten
a ticket cops aren't camped out you see
cops in LA wait for you to come to them
they set up little traps at the bottom
of hills sitting there like [ __ ] with
their [ __ ] radar guns all you got to
do is look in your rear-view mirror you
don't see a cop there drive right on
through that's another thing I would do
if I was in charge have the cops start
serving the [ __ ] people to protect
and serve not hand out [ __ ]
tickets and annoy what's a mayor
Corollas drug policy listen do whatever
the [ __ ] you want to do whenever you
want to do it and unless you harm
somebody else or put them in jeopardy
[ __ ] it you want smoke weed you want to
grow pot plantation on your own house
pay [ __ ] taxes do whatever you want
you want to get really high and go drive
speed through a neighborhood then we
have a problem you want to do a little
blow you want to do a little crank you
wanna do a little speed whatever the
[ __ ] you want to do go feel free to do
it start hurting somebody then we come
down on you clear out the [ __ ]
prisons with all this [ __ ] consensual
crime [ __ ] you know prostitution or
victimless [ __ ] and drugs I mean a lot
of it you know
look you're selling mushrooms at a Phish
concert the [ __ ] do I want you're in our
prisons for I'm only looking for people
that pose a threat and by the way I
don't give a [ __ ] they pose a threat to
themselves either that's another thing
like you want to kill yourself that's
fine under my administration that's
Darwin just taking out the garbage
I want the cops to focus on crime
instead of being little money collectors
running around raping everyone's [ __ ]
wallet I'm gonna bring back the
policemen's ball they can sell tickets
with some goddamn dignity and that's
where they'll get their [ __ ]
walking-around money or Wham as I call
it it sounds like you might be a
libertarian
I just like cherry pick all the best
stuff out of all the political parties
is a libertarian then then so be it
the more money you give the politicians
the less you get I know that taxing the
[ __ ] and I would shut down the lottery
I'd get rid of the [ __ ] lottery it's
the worst message you can send to but
legalized poker yes of course you want
to play [ __ ] 21 play 21 I have this
thing it's like well it's legal to play
pan and pie Gow Poker but you can't play
21 look either you're [ __ ] gambling
or you're not you know what I mean the
lotteries the worst [ __ ] form of
gambling which is endorsed by the state
so get rid of the [ __ ] lottery it
supports two schools right everyone gets
behind that it's all about the schools
how much schools better now number forty
years ago if you are a guidance
counselor and some kid came in your
office and this is like I don't know
what do you think I should do and you
went you better play the lottery
you get your ass fired right so why are
we connecting this horrible [ __ ]
form of gambling with our crumbling
school system if they're not trying to
make it better one more month but this
money work ok we got a we got a tax the
rich more so we get more money for what
for what so you could have another
[ __ ] up school for what what are you
gonna do with our money
all you do is [ __ ] wasted